lâche impôts un événement truc les deux
stars à l'hôtel level de los angeles a
été pris d'assaut par des hommes armés
images filmées en direct par l'un des
assaillants nous confirmons que l'un des
otages et la star de la pop
internationale
shaggy tué bacha qui [ __ ] je me trouve
chaque dj qui s'est planté 3 me fassih
shaggy a tout faux kevin est requis
non
nous avons trois serveurs en fuite je
pense qu'on devrait se rendre on était
proches genre montrent que je suis pas
armés on peut se les faire
je m'appelle alex avec 3 x on va devoir
les exploser ces [ __ ] 3x veut dire
présent en fait c'est aussi un film avec
vin diesel
lessivé mais de bien
allons [ __ ] le bordel
non
[ __ ] le clc
rinne ces transporteurs c'est parti
est ce que vous faites là haut je sois
le je t'emmerde salque à vue sont là
pour nous aider c'est quoi ton problème
c'est complètement bidon d'être sauvé
par la police tu écoutes du kendrick
lamar oiseaux comment j'ai pu être pote
avec un looser comme toi toutes ces
années je suis pas un looser méga stop
tht a tiré sur moi à côté de toi bouffon